hey 42 here it is very rarely used but
the word nibble means half of a computer
bite welcome to RIF in Bolivia llama
droppings are used to purify water to
keep yourself out as a real-life batsman
would cost around 300 million dollars
18% of the average Americans income is
spent on transportation chemicals cost
female munitions workers in the first
world war to give birth to yellow babies
there are more stars in the universe
than words that have been spoken by all
of the humans who have ever lived a day
on the International Space Station is
one and a half hours long
only six out of 22 crocodile species
actually present any danger to humans
until 1900 visitors to Stonehenge were
given chisels so they could chip off a
souvenir there are more species of
plants on Cape Town's Table Mountain
than in the whole of the UK the Queen's
staff get to choose their own Christmas
presents which must be worth between 20
and 25 pounds Picasso painted using
ordinary house paint the United States
has never lost a war in which donkeys
were used it is cheaper to send Scottish
cards to China to be fileted and sent
back again than to fill at the fish in
Scotland's Heineken beer is designed to
foam for precisely five minutes in 19th
century Britain attempting to commit
suicide was against the law and was
punishable by death
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2